des pépites du tennis mondial à
feucherolles ce week-end les jeunes
joueuses sont venus participer pendant
trois jours à la winter cup une
compétition majeure chez les moins de 12
ans organisé pour la première fois au
comité des yvelines au le niveau est
très très haut puisque on a maintenant
des jeunes filles de 12 ans et moi c'est
vraiment un niveau de jeu et au niveau
physique et au niveau technique et au
niveau tactique très très élevé au total
sept pays étaient représentés pendant la
compétition dont la france les joueuses
se sont affrontées sur le modèle de la
fête que ouais je trouve ça bien parce
que bon c'est bien organisé et après le
club est bien et les perf en cours c'est
un super tournoi c'est vraiment sympa ça
apporte de l'expérience avec un haut
niveau de tennis c'est vraiment sympa et
j'aime ça en plus du spectacle sur les
terrains les supporters ont pu voir une
autre star le vrai trophée de la fed cup
certains n'ont pas hésité à immortaliser
le moment on a pu prendre des petites
photos avec
donc c'est très chouette toit très sympa
la compétition a finalement été remporté
par la pologne 2 à 1 face à l'angleterre
la france termine 5e
vu le succès rencontré cette année le
comité des yvelines va organiser une
nouvelle winter cup au même date l'année
prochaine